[Música]
yo no es 100 millones 80
y me voy a estallar porque al final de
la historia vamos a llegar de nuevo por
allá
vamos mil veces 85 que pasó en 85 en la
ciudad de méxico
es un terremoto uno de los terremotos y
uno de los momentos más trágicos en la
historia de la ciudad de méxico y por
qué voy allá me paso 80 85 porque es la
primera cosa que yo me acuerdo en la
vida
me acuerdo que yo estaba vivía en una
colonia que se llama en el sur de la
ciudad méxico se recolocan que es la
campestre churubusco y me acuerdo como
todo se empezaba a mecer y yo no
entendía nada
y salimos de la casa y pasó lo que pasó
todos sabemos la historia y qué pasó
pero como le explicaban o le explicas
eso aún un niño de cinco años que su
primer recuerdo de vida mi primer
recuerdo de vida resultó o resulta que
sea algo terrorífico es un recuerdo de
muerte cuando uno por lo general
lo primero que se debe acordar en la
vida es no sé de un juego de cómo se
mecía en un halago yo me acuerdo como se
mecía
se mecía la ciudad y cuando le pregunté
a mis padres y les pregunté a mis
conocidos que lo que pasaba
lo que pasaba se cae la ciudad se pueden
caer los edificios la tierra está viva
con que la tierra está vida que me están
hablando entonces después les pregunté
qué pasa si uno se queda aplastado en
los edificios pues probablemente te
puedes quedar ahí atrapado por mucho
tiempo y también después me dijeron te
puedes morir
y en ese momento les pregunté
qué significa morir
y la respuesta me pareció
me espanto mucho me dijeron que te
quedabas dormido para siempre y después
acudir con otras personas y otras y
otras preguntas y me decían pues te
quedas eternamente con dios y ninguna de
las dos respuestas me parecía a mí una
respuesta lógica y me causaba mucho
miedo pensar en el hecho de la eternidad
la eternidad al lado de un dios o le
termine a todo el tiempo dormido para un
niño de cinco años porque lo digo y
porque empiezo por ahí porque ese
momento marcó mi vida marca mi vida
porque empiezo a ser un niño muy
nervioso a partir de estos primeros
recuerdos yo soy un niño el clásico que
va la la la
a la primaria
y es el que está haciendo las cosas en
la clase el que no pone atención y los
maestros me empiezan a catalogar y
empiezan a poner etiquetas no es que es
un desastre es hiperactivo no se está va
a estar quieto pero es muy creativo
y así fue creciendo y fue fue fui
avanzando llegó la secundaria en la
secundaria pasó exactamente lo mismo yo
todavía no podía y no no conseguía que
lo que estaba pasando es que yo en ese
momento seguía espantado por un momento
que me había marcado en la vida al
principio yo crecí viendo estas imágenes
de tlatelolco derrumbado y con esas
imágenes del hotel regis derrumbado y
entonces llegué a la secundaria y como
llega a la secundaria todos sabemos aquí
los que tengan hijos adolescentes o
todos hemos sido el momento les cnte
sabemos que eso se vuelve un desastre y
un desastre cuando uno está espantado
angustiado y no saben qué es lo que
tiene el niño en este caso ya un
adolescente pues entonces pasó lo que
tenía que pasar empecé a conocer la
fiesta empecé a conocer otras cosas
y yo quise tranquilizar mi miedo y mis
angustias tomando y entonces mi primera
borrachera fue los 15 años me tomé unos
tequilas en la clásica fiesta de la
prepa de la secundaria y me pongo muy
mal y no entendía por qué pero bueno era
una manera cómo tratar de calmar algo
que yo llevaba dentro que me estaba
matando de miedo que en ese momento no
sabía que estaba pasando
también sigo en la secundaria ahí voy
con las calificaciones me dicen en ese
momento algo que también me marca me
dicen que tiene déficit de atención
entonces pues no se puede controlar no
se puede concentrar en nada tiene que
tiene que estar en todos lados o tengo
que estar en todos lados y entonces el
estos ochos con estos chiquitos ya el
doctor ya con esto va a estar quieto
pero resulta que en ese momento yo
también pregunté y puedo tomar y los
chochos no entonces yo por el lado la
ciudad los tiraba entonces empezaba pues
prefería el nivel de la fiesta con eso
pero no soluciona absolutamente nada
llegó la preparatoria llega la
preparatoria en donde otra vez seguimos
con esta historia yo no era un niño o
nerón no era una persona soy una persona
mala
muchos me catalogaban las calificaciones
porque no podía poner atención porque
simplemente no sabía estar quieto
entonces llega la preparatoria y la
preparatoria marca otra vez todavía hace
más grande el incendio la preparatoria
de tres años y resulta que yo lo hago en
cuatro y en cuatro escuelas distintas o
sea lo que uno debe haber estado en una
escuela durante tres años a lo mucho
cuatro
en una misma escuela yo la hago en
cuatro escuelas distintas y acabo
planeando literal así como el plano
cayéndose cayendo a la universidad no sé
cómo llegar a universidad pero en la
preparatoria me marca también una cosa
muy importante me marca mi abuelo me
regaló una cámara
una cámara pentax yo soy la generación
de las últimas generaciones
que aprendimos a tomar fotografías con
película en análogo le decimos no
existía lo digital y cuando yo veo esa
cámara me emociono y empieza a tomar
fotos y es cuando llega una primera idea
y un primer romance con la fotografía
estoy en el cuarto oscuro y cuando estoy
revelando y veo que aparece la imagen en
el cuarto oscuro
los fotógrafos que han estado en un
cuarto oscuro por primera vez se
entenderán de lo que estoy diciendo y
surgió un amor a primera vista y
surgiendo tranquilidad dentro de mí y
empecé a tomar fotografías para estar en
el cuarto oscuro y la gente de cine me
reconocía es bueno es muy bueno sigue
así fui en escuela empecé a los 15 años
era el menor de una clase de una escuela
fotografía muy famosa y me fui
reconocido
pero vuelvo a pasar lo mismo el interés
estaba por otro lado yo seguí angustiado
por lo que ahora ya sé qué me pasaba
antes no lo sabía pero entonces empiezo
este camino por el otro lado y acabó
vendiendo mi cámara el empeño para
dedicarme a la fiesta otra vez y
recuerdo que otra vez llegó a la
universidad la universidad siguió igual
y no sé qué es lo que me está pasando en
ese momento pasa otra cosa muy momento
un momento que me marca mucho en mi vida
y es que muere mi abuelo muere mi abuelo
y es un momento importante para mí
porque porque mi abuelo era alcohólico
mi abuelo era una gran persona era un
ejemplo para mí pero todos le comparaban
con el abuelo eres como el abuelo eres
como el abuelo y otra vez poniendo esas
etiquetas que tanto hacen daño que no
nos damos cuenta pero que hacen daño que
van marcando el camino de una persona
muchas personas ahora hablan bien de mi
abuelo y sé que es una buena persona
pero también hablaban mal de él y decían
que era incontrolable a esa persona que
no querían que vivieran navidad que no
querían que vivieran año nuevo porque
arruinar a todas las fiestas qué es lo
que pasó cuando lo vi morir lo vi morir
espantado algo tenía el que no había
resuelto en su vida lo vi sentado y tuve
una charla con él muy íntima y cuando
salgo de ahí de la plática un par de
días después muere
y en ese momento
si no le pongo freno a esto
voy a morir igual y listo igual lo digo
de una manera sin resolver un problema
sin resolver un miedo que pasó que en
ese momento digo a ver paso número uno
vamos a dejar de ver voy a dejar de
beber voy a empezar a dedicarme a otras
cosas dedicarme a la fotografía y es en
la universidad cuando estoy en el taller
de fotografía cuando empiezo a través a
tomar fotografías y empiezo a encontrar
un camino pero a la par sigo por acá un
año dejó de tomar otro otro año igual la
universidad igual que la preparatoria en
44 años tres años solo acaba sino en
cinco acabo tenido me trae mi primer
trabajo a los 25 26 años las personas
que me conocen de esa época que hoy me
ven me dicen como le hiciste de verdad
que pensábamos que iba a ser un
fracasado que no ibas a lograr
absolutamente nada en la vida pero qué
pasa cuando tengo esta idea también
y salir en la preparatoria tratar de
resolver entre la terapia por un gran
amigo pone no se deprimen se lee muy
caro y sí pero también empecé y quería
empezar a resolver mis problemas que es
lo que me estaba pasando todo esto que
les empezó a contar hasta es unos
poquitos minutos yo no lo sabía en ese
momento yo no sabía era tan fácil que
haberme dicho a ver el niño chiquito ven
no pasa nada un abrazo y el mejor no me
ha cambiado todo pero no sabemos muchas
veces que después de mucho trabajo
sabemos qué es lo que nos pasó y es
cuando llega otro momento llega aparece
la cámara digital y entonces la cámara
digital que además graba hace una cámara
muy famosa que se llama 5d tomó
fotografías con esa puedo hacer vídeo y
sorpresa
esa cámara revoluciona el mercado porque
porque puedo hacer lo que estaba
puede hacer cine se vuelve un poquito
más democrático la tecnología es lo que
está siendo democratizando un poco los
dos medios y lo que me lleva también a
que de pronto llegue el drone y llegue
el tornillo cuando lo veo digo que es
eso yo lo quiero porque porque veo que
con eso puede explotar todo lo que yo
quiero hacer que quiero hacer tomar
fotografías donde quiero yo me gusta
mucho tomar fotografías de la ciudad de
mexico
me subí a la torre latino me subí a la
torre de pemex y con cuando vi el dron
dije ya no necesito más permisos ya
puedo tomar una foto donde quiera
inclusive en los pinos
pero
todo eso llevó un proceso y un proceso
que tuve que trabajar muchísimo dejarlo
de hacer estuve mucho tiempo en el área
de publicidad se empezó a reconocer en
la publicidad porque era bueno tomando
fotos porque era bueno haciendo videítos
porque hice un vídeo biólogo de los
pumas
hice un vídeo cuando los pumas fue
campeón hace tanto tiempo que yorke de
nosotros ya no va a pasar pobres pumas
pero fue esto se hizo viral que es que
es que se hizo viral lo vieron un millón
de personas como quería un millón de
personas mi vídeo y es cuando empiezo a
descubrir que algo mi trabajo y para lo
que soy bueno y también a partir de un
trabajo que lo que empiezo a hacer a
trabajar con el psicoanálisis y con
terapias y yo sólo entonces eso me lleva
a un trabajo profesional a este vídeo de
los pumas y aún otros vídeos más llegó
al momento de la publicidad y hay algo
en ese momento que me aburre por
completo
algo me estaba vaciando no sabía que ya
lo había logrado tenía grandes marcas
arriba trabajando pero no me motivaba no
sé por qué me aburría y entonces qué
pasó
resulta que tuve una recaída alcohólica
muy fuerte pero muy fuerte tuvieron que
ir por mí a la calle y hablaron por
teléfono
unas personas que quiero mucho que les
agradezco fueron por mí pero resulta que
estamos hablando de eso de hace un año
hace no tanto y qué pasa
que dos días después tiempo y se cae las
medias ciudades seca en la ciudad
entonces me reencontré con todos mis
miedos me reencontré con el terremoto
recontra con mis propios problemas y es
cuando digo la vida a veces te ponen
unas cosas y unas señales tan claras
tuve un derrumbe personal
y dos días después se derrumba en la
ciudad
me encontraba de nuevo otra vez cuando
tenía cinco años
qué pasó en ese momento que
instintivamente salí a tomar fotografías
de los derrumbes con el dron desde
arriba con las técnicas que ya había
aprendido y que había aprendido porque
también no era todo malo
a los 15 años empezó a tomar fotografías
y me encontré con el derrumbe encontré
con el temblor con mi monstruo lo ataque
ni siquiera pensando en eso no me pongo
ahorita soy el valiente que fui a
hacerlo lo hice de una manera instintiva
sabía cómo retratar lo en el terremoto
yo sabía que volver a pasar y sabemos
que puede volver a pasar porque vivimos
en una zona sísmica
y punto hay dos cosas que podemos hacer
cuando suene la alerta sísmica saber qué
hacer y asumirlo o nunca hacerle caso y
cuando suele salir pavoroso y corriendo
por aquí afuera hice un documental que a
partir que no es una coincidencia estoy
retratando mis miedos esto soy una
persona que lleva viviendo 38 años de
vida la ciudad méxico solamente la
ciudad de mexico es algo que es mío que
me pertenece y que le pertenece a todas
las personas que vivimos en ese momento
del temblor hoy en día me puedo
considerar que soy un fotógrafo
independiente que estoy en camino de
conseguir cosas que no sé hasta dónde
voy a llegar pero hoy en día ya puedo
decir que estoy mucho más tranquilo que
sé que me pasó y que sigo trabajando día
con día para poder crear y estar
tranquilo y para poder llegar al momento
que llegó mi abuelo y poder decir bueno
voy a estirar las patas pero una manera
tranquila
y espero que bueno que reflexionemos
porque esto no se puede disfrutar muchas
gracias
[Música]